Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Ben biraz değişik bir konu seçmeye
gayret ettim, biraz ufkumuz açılsın diye.
Bu sahneyi hatırlayanlarınız vardır belki.
Stanley Kubrick'in meşhur
''2001: Space Odyssey'' filminin
ilk sahnesi.
Bu aslında biziz; ilkel insan.
Ben size burada Neandertal'den,
Homosapiens'den başlayan bir
yolculuğu anlatacağım ve bunu
günümüzdeki teknolojiyle birleştireceğim.
Umuyorum keyifli vakit geçirirsiniz, biraz
da zihninizi çalıştırmaya yardımcı olurum.
Bu gördüğünüz, ilk bilgisayarlardan biri.
Soğutma sistemlerini görüyorsunuz.
İnanılmaz büyük bir ekipman.
Milyonlarca dolara yapılıyor ve bugün
cebinizde kullandığınız bir hesap
makinesinden daha az işlemci gücü var.
Apollo Ay'a gittiğinde,
32 kiloluk bir bilgisayar taşıyor
ve bugün kolunuza taktığınız saatten,
daha düşük bir işlemci seviyesinde
bir işlem gücü var.
Bunları çalıştırmak için
ciddi sayıda insan gücü,
inanılmaz ciddi bir elektrik enerjisi,
çok ciddi soğutma sistemleri gerekiyordu.
Şimdi ne kadar ufaldığını biliyorsunuz.
Şimdi aslında dünyada
dijital bir devrim yaşanıyor.
[Maliyetler düşüyor] Dijital devrimin en
büyük etkeni aslında bu grafik.
Bu, dünyadaki transistör fiyatları.
Yani 75 senesinde,
1 milyona değil 2 bin dolar o zamanın
parası, yani bugünün aşağı yukarı
8 bin doları ediyor olan transistör
fiyatları, şu anda 25 sent seviyesine
gerilemiş durumda.
İnanılmaz bir ucuzlama,
inanılmaz bir küçülme var.
Dolayısıyla birim işlem maliyeti
dramatik şekilde düşüyor,
hesaplama gücü neredeyse sonsuza gidiyor.
İnsan zayıf bir varlık,
biz kusurlu varlıklarız.
Beyin gücümüz bir yere kadar.
Hesap yeteneğimiz bir yere kadar.
Dünya tarihinde ilk defa
önümüzdeki yıllarda,
insanlığın toplam beyin gücünün daha
üstünde işlem yapabilecek bilgisayarları,
şu anda laboratuvarlarda test ediyorlar,
bunların altyapıları hazır,
yakında çalışmaya başlayacak.
Dolayısıyla, insan kendi
kusurlarının farkında olduğu için,
yani zayıf varlığının
farkında olduğu için,
bunu makinelerle etrafını kontrol ederek,
sonra kendini kontrol ederek
düzeltmeye çalışıyor.
Bunları başardığımız gün, bambaşka
bir dünya ile karşı karşıya olacağız.
Bu, sıradan bir oturma odası.
İşte bir tane kanepe, işte müzik sistemi,
ses sistemi, televizyon, işte saksınız,
perdeniz var.
Şimdi insan; inlerde, mağaralarda
başladığı yolculuğuna,
daha konforlu yaşayabilmek için,
iklimin kontrollü, kendine daha rahat
barınma sağlayan binalarda,
evlerde yaşıyor.
Bu da aslında,
şu anda veyahutta önümüzdeki yıllarda,
evinizdeki işlemciler.
Her kırmızı yuvarlağı
bir işlemci olarak düşünün.
Lambalar işlemci ile kontrol edilecek,
dışarıdaki güneş ışığına göre
panjurlarınız açılacak kapanacak.
Zaten ses sistemi, müzik sistemi, bunların
kumandaları, televizyonlar, hoparlörler,
masanın içinde minderin içinde siz
otururken nabzınızı ölçecek,
vücut sıcaklığınızı ölçecek, bir sıkıntı
varsa doktorunuza rapor gidecek.
Şimdi birinci aşamayı atlattık;
yani insan artık iklimi kontrollü,
kendini dış etkenlerden koruyabildiği,
regüle ettiği bir ortamda yaşıyor.
Bu odada oturduğunuz sürece de, günde
ortalama 50 GB veriye maruz kalıyorsunuz.
Oturduğunuz sürece demeyeyim,
bir gün içinde.
İşte bunun içinde televizyon, radyo,
telefon, basılı materyal, bilgisayar,
insanlarla iletişim, her şey var.
Bir insan günde takribi
50 GB veriye maruz kalıyor,
ve bu şu anki teknolojiyle nedeniyle yılda
ortalama %6 artarak devam ediyor.
Şimdi ikinci seviye başlıyor;
giyilebilir teknolojiler.
Yani bir insanın dışarıdan isteyerek ve
istemeyerek maruz kaldığı veri akışı var,
bir de kendi vücudunun ürettiği ve
aslında bugüne kadar problem yaşamadıkça,
yani aslında bozulmadıkça ölçmediğimiz
bir sürü veri üretiyoruz.
Kimse hastalanmadıkça
gidip tahlil yaptırmıyor.
Kimse kendini kötü hissetmezse
ya da biri zorlamazsa doktora gidip
vücuduna ölçüm yaptırmıyor.
Dolayısıyla kimse, vücudunda
neler olup bittiğini bilmiyor.
Şimdi bu da değişmek üzere.
Artık işte kolumuzdaki saat, üzerimizdeki
kıyafet, ayağımızdaki ayakkabı,
saçımızdaki toka, dişimizdeki dolgu,
her şey veri toplamaya başlayacak.
Ve dünya tarihinde ilk defa,
insan vücuduyla ilgili toplanan
bu büyük data sayesinde,
biz hastalanmadan
hastalanacağımızı anlayıp
hatta biz anlamadan vücuda daha
düşük dozda ilaç zerkedebilecek.
Acil bir durumda doktorumuzu,
bizim haberimiz bile olmadan haberdar
edebilecek, bize veri akışı sağlayarak
yememize, içmemize, hareketimize karışacak
ve bizim daha sağlıklı
insan olmamızı sağlayacak.
1820 senesinde Hollanda ordusu,
askere giren erkeklerin
boylarını ölçmeye başlıyor.
Hollanda Avrupa'nın en kısa ulusu o zaman.
Ortalama boy 1,60-1,63.
1,63'ten başlıyorlar, şu anda 1,83.
Aşağı yukarı 150 senede, 200 senede,
30 küsür santim insanların boyu uzuyor.
Bu da diğer ülkeler,
bizde zaten böyle bir veri
olmadığı için ben Türkiye'yi koyamadım,
bizde istatistikler biraz geç başlamış.
Şimdi, önce boyumuz uzadı.
Yani fiziksel koşullarımız gelişiyor.
Bunun sebebi, dediğim gibi eve taşındık,
daha iyi beslenmeye başladık,
kontrollü iklim; yani artık ısıtma
sistemleri var, soğutma sistemleri var.
Gıdalar daha temiz.
Daha kontrollü ortamlarda yaşıyoruz.
Ulaşım kolaylaştı;, her yere gitmek için
kilometrelerce yürümek, koşmak,
ata binmek zorunda kalmıyoruz.
Taşıma sistemleri çok gelişti,
dolayısıyla insanlar rahatladılar.
Ağır yük kaldırmayı bıraktık,
boyumuz uzadı.
Dolayısıyla daha sağlıklı,
daha güçlü nesiller geliyor.
Şimdi, yeni bir devrim daha kapıda.
Artık DNA'yı analiz etmiş durumdayız.
DNA'ya müdahale edilmeye başlandı,
bundan 8-10 sene evvel biliyorsunuz
dünyada ilk defa koyun kopyalandı.
Şu anda, çocukların
cinsiyetini belirlemek için,
belli ülkelerde ahlaken hoş karşılanmasa
da, teknik olarak çocuğunuzun cinsiyetini
aslında hamilelik esnasında
değiştirtebiliyorsunuz.
Kız olsun, erkek olsuna
müdahale edebiliyorsunuz.
Bunların tabii ki ileride,
belli müdahalelerin belli problemlere
yol açtığı görülecek.
Belli müdahalelerin de aslında
belli problemleri ortaya çıkmadan
düzelttiğini göreceğiz.
Şimdi aslında bütün bu süreç,
insanın kendi kusurlarını gidermek
istemesinden kaynaklanıyor.
Biz, hâlâ dünyanın %75'i okyanus,
nefesimizi tutarak 1,5-2 dakika
kalabiliyoruz, hani çok özel bir durumda
3 dakika kalabiliyoruz.
30-40 metrenin altına,
çok olimpik bir sporcu değilseniz,
100 metrenin altına inemiyoruz.
Yani dünyanın %75'ini, herhangi bir
ekipman olmadan kullanamıyoruz.
Yerden yüksekte hareket edemiyoruz.
Belli bir yüksekliğin üstünde, teneffüs
ederken oksijensizlikten problem yaşıyoruz
dolayısıyla bunları hep bugüne
kadar hep makinelerle giderdik.
İşte dalış ekipmanları yaptık, daha
derine inmek için denizaltılar yaptık,
dağa çıkarken oksijen tüpleri taşıdık.
İşte yüksek irtifada daha hızlı
gidilebildiği için uçaklar imâl edildi.
Şimdi artık DNA'yla,
belki hibrid insan türevleri çıkacak
ve farklı ortamlarda,
daha dayanıklı insanlar oluşacak.
Şimdi insandaki bir zayıflık da;
biz yaşlanıyoruz, hastalanıyoruz.
Bu DNA ile hastalıklar
giderilmeye başlandı.
İlaç teknolojisi çok gelişti.
Bundan sonraki adımda,
eskiyen organlarımız, çabuk yıpranan
organlarımızı, üç boyutlu printer ile
basacağız ve değiştireceğiz.
Bu çok uzak gibi gelmesin,
bu gördüğünüz bir kulak.
Bu sunumu hazırlarken bulduk,
bayağı bir kulak yapılmış durumda.
Şu anda,
organik madde basan, yani hücre
seviyesinde baskı teknolojisi
dünyada geliştirilmiş durumda.
Tabii bunları henüz daha insanlara takıp
denemediler ama belli bir süre sonra,
işte nedir insanın
en çabuk eskiyen organı, göz.
30-40 yaşına geliyorsunuz,
gözleriniz bozulmaya başlıyor.
Çıkartacaklar yenisini takacaklar.
Dolayısıyla göz diye
bir problem kalmayacak.
Belki belli meslek gruplarına özel
farklı tip gözler olacak.
İşte keskin göz olacak, ne bileyim
daha gevşek göz olacak gibi gibi.
Dolayısıyla,
dünyada ortalama yaşam
son 70-80 sene içinde,
47'lerden, bu dünya ortalaması,
yani gelişmiş ülkelerde bu yine 80'lerin
üzerine çıkıyor Japonya gibi yerlerde.
Afrika gibi yerlerde biraz daha düşük.
47'den 78'e kadar, 2040'a kadar
çıkacağı öngörülüyor.
Benim öngörümde,
bu hastalıklar tedavi edildikten sonra,
organlar değiştirilebilir
hale geldikten sonra,
2000'li yılların herhangi bir yerinde,
sonlarına doğru muhtemelen
sonsuz yaşam bizi bekliyor olacak.
Sonsuz yaşam, insanlığın devam
etmesi için en önemli koşul.
Çünkü dünyada kısıtlı kaynaklarımız var,
bu kaynaklar bir süre sonra bitecek,
ne kadar dikkat edersek edelim,
bunlar bir şekilde bize yetmeyecek,
ve bizim uzayda
kolonileşmeye ihtiyacımız var.
Bununla ilgili çalışmalar, biliyorsunuz
çok hızlı şekilde devam ediyor.
Şimdi, 10 sene evvel atılan uydulardan
biri şu anda Plüto'ya varmış durumda.
Yeni yeni fotoğraf yollamaya başladı,
birkaç aydır yaklaşmaya devam ediyor.
Plüto aslında bize yakın bir gezegen
diyeceğim, biliyorsunuz gezegendi eskiden,
şimdi artık gezegen demiyorlar,
Güneş sistemimizin en dışındaki
kitlelerden biri diyeyim.
4,28 milyar kilometre.
4,28 milyar kilometre, uzay ölçeğinde
bir saç telinin ini kadar bir şey düşünün.
Hiçbir şey değil.
Şu anki teknoloji ile bizim oraya
gitmemiz on sene sürüyor.
Ve buraya insansız araçla gidiyoruz,
yani bunun içine insan koymaya çalışsak,
orada atmosferik koşul oluştursak,
10 senelik yemeğini,
içeceğini koymaya çalışsak,
hadi yanına bir de arkadaş koyduk,
operasyon inanılmaz maliyetli olacak,
hacim büyüyecek, hızlara çıkamayacak.
Belli hızların üstünde insan ölecek,
zaten 10 sene gitti, dönüş bileti yok
gibi gibi problemler var.
Dolayısıyla bunu çözmenin tek yolu,
insanların çok çok daha uzun yaşaması.
Çok çok daha uzun yaşayabilirsek,
evet bir gün Plüto'ya gidebileceğiz.
Şimdi dünyada iki gelişme oluyor.
Bir; bizim ömrümüz uzuyor,
yaşam kalitemiz gelişiyor.
İki; teknoloji gelişiyor, transistör
fiyatları düşüyor, hız artıyor.
Fakat hızın da
bir sınırı var biliyorsunuz.
Şu andaki fizik bilgilerimize göre,
hızın limiti ışık hızı.
Şimdi dolayısıyla dünyaya, eğer
Güneş sisteminin dışında düşünürsek,
en yakın gezegen 4.37 ışık yılı uzaklıkta.
Yani ışık hızında dahi gitseniz,
4,5 senede birinci,
yani en yakın gezegene gidebiliyorsunuz.
Orada bir şey bulamadınız, ikinciye
gideyim deseniz, bir bu kadar daha.
Üçüncüye gideyim deseniz,
bir bu kadar daha.
Önümüzde dev gibi bir uzay var,
milyarlarca nüfusumuz var.
Kesinlikle medeniyetin devamı uzayda
kolonileşmede olacağı için,
insanlığın hız, yaşam ve sağlık
problemlerini çözmesi lazım.
Beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ediyorum.
Umarım beğenmişsinizdir.
Sağ olun.
(Alkış)